يمكن التحدي هو قبل ما تدخل الحرب دائما
المعاناه يعني لو تتكلم على موضوع
الروحانيه روحانيه كلها ترا تتلف وتنتهي
في المشقه اللي قاعده تصاحبك من يوم ما
طلعت المطار لان توصل لبوابه الحرب من
ناحيه الطرق من ناحيه الزحام من ناحيه
وضوح المسارات المروريه يعني انت تستاجر
في الغرفه وما تدري المرور بخليك تدخل
لصوص المنطقه كلها هيرمونك تحت في الجيب
وتاخذ شنطتك تركض الدوره ال- ال- الفندق
حقك اعطيك معلومه رسميه موجوده
81% من الفنادق اللي موجود من الفنادق
اللي موجوده في مكه 81% اقل من فئه ثلاثه
اشهر
[موسيقى]
هلا سكراب من الاذاعه الثمانيه وانا عمر
الجريسي استضيف قاعده التحول وقاده
الاعمال وقاده الراي وسولف معهم على
المستجدات ومستهدفات رؤيه السعوديه 20 30
ضيف حلقه اليوم والاستاذ ياسر ابو عتيق
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه ام القرى للتنميه
والاعمار المالك والمطور لمشروع وجهه مسار
في مكه المكرمه
الحلقه
ربطتها
بالتحديات اللي كنت اشوفها في تجربه ضيف
الرحمن او تجربه الزهراء اللي مكه المكرمه
طوال السنوات الماضيه وكنت اقرا هذه
التحديات في وثيقه برنامج خدمه الضيوف
الرحمن اللي يغطي هذا الجانب لكن بكل
صراحه الفتره الماضيه ما كان في همم
التغير الملموس الكبير همم في هذا الملف
بعدين لما سمعت عن هذا الشركه وعن هذا
المشروع
اللي تملك الدوله في اكثر من 60% ااه شعرت
بتكون حلقه جميله اننا نضرب مثال لنموذج
التطوير اللي نامله في المنطقه المركزيه
لمكه المكرمه همم نضرب مثال لكيف تكون
تجربه ضيف الرحمن اللي نطمحلها همم في همم
تلك البقعه المباركه السعوديه اعزه الله
خدمه همم الحرمين الشريفين الخدمه الضيوف
الرحمن بشكل غير مسبوق في التاريخ وكلنا
كادي السعوديين نفتخر بان قائدنا هو خادم
الحرمين الشريفين وكلنا خدام الحرمين
الشريفين لكن احنا نتكلم على تجربه ما قبل
الوصول لمبنى الحرم وتجربه ما بعد الخروج
من مبنى الحرم هذه فيها تحديات مرتبطه
بسهوله الحركه ارصفه مشاهده صديقه للانسان
تشجير همم خيارات سكن متنوعه مستوى خدمات
وخيارات اثرائيه وثقافيه متكامله وتخلي
تجربتك ما هي مجرد تجربه تجربه للمكان
تعتبر باسرع وقت ممكن تغادر المكان همم
هذه على ال- ال- ال- ال- ال-
المقدسه شرفها الله همم يمكن ان يصنع منها
همم شيء اكبر بكثير همم كتجربه متكامله
فهذا كان تركيز على همم نموذج هذا الشركه
اللي تبغى تصنع هذه التجربه المختلفه
اتكلمنا على قصه الشركه تاسيسها اسباب
التاخر الطويل في مرحله همم التخطيط
والتاسيس وبعدين تكلمنا على وش مكونات
وجهه مسار عدد الابراج
المرافق الاخرى همم مسارات مسارات النقل
همم العام مسرات السيارات ارتباطها بقطار
الحرمين همم وغيرها من نقاط كلمنا على همم
مساهمتهم في زياده الغطاء النباتي على
موضوع نسبه المحتوى المحلي في انفاقهم
اللي انفقوا الفتره الماضيه وتكلمنا على
بعدين تكلمنا بشكل عام على همم
المنطقه وعلى
دور هيئه دور الهيئه الملكيه لمكه المكرمه
في الفتره الماضيه واللي يمكن لبعض يرى
انه كان بامكان افضل من ذلك بكثير وبعد
ذلك ختمنا بالحديث عن دور هذه الشركه في
تنميه المجتمع المحلي للتدريب وتاهيل
ومساعده ابناء مكه على تطوير انفسهم
اترككم مع الحوار حياك الله ابو عبد
العزيز شرفت ونورتنا حياك انا سعيد بوجودك
ابو عبد العزيز هذه المحجبه ولا الناريه
ولا مين هذه ما شاء الله تعرفهم عندك
علاقه خاصه مع العصير صحيح هذه البندوس
الله يسلمك لما نكون في جو مخلص اي شيء
تكون موجوده والله مؤشر مو طيب خلص الحلقه
ولا ايه ابدا ابدا بالعكس هذه تخلي
الاشياء بصير بافضل بشكل ممكن
كم عصايه عندك
بلاش نعد عندي اوص كثير
القصه بسيطه جدا كنت في رحله بريه 20 سنه
تقريبا
بتعرف رحلات البريه توقف مكان تنزل تاخذ
اغراض اي شيء تحتاجه مويه مش عارف انا
واقف ما كتبها شيء شفت عاصفه
يستخدم
اخذتها معي من وقتها ما ترك العصا عجبتني
يعني في ناس
كان الفتنه شكل في البدايه
بعدين تطورت المساله
خفه العصايه نوع الخشب
الان صار عندي خبره جيده واجتماعيا
[موسيقى]
العقاري في مكه المكرمه او في المنطقه حتى
من هذه الزاويه احنا نسولف عن الشركه
وهي من زوايا الرؤيه اللي ما قد تتركنا
لها في بوت كاستقراط اللي هي موضوع خدمه
ضيوف الرحمن
وتحسين وتطوير تجربه الزائر في منطقه مكه
المكرمه فخلينا نبدا بدنا نقول والشمسار
مسار الله يسلمك قبل ما ابدا ابغى ارجع
لطول المده بس خلينا نبدا بالمسار مسار هي
وجهها
تعيش
تعمل
تستمتع
فيها بجوار الحرام
معنى
نحن هيكون عندنا
نظام حياه متكامل
اذا نتكلم على رؤيا مجتمع حيوي
وظائف
فنادق مطاعم
مقاهي متاحف
بطول 3 كيلو ونص
عرضه 60 متر
في النص في كل الانشطه والفعاليات اللي
تحتاجها مدينه مكه احنا بنحاول ما بنحاول
نعيد الحياه بجوار الحرام باذن الله
وهنكتب خدمات متكامله سواء كانت خدمات
ضيافه فندقيه سكن وظائف فهي وجهها
تحتوي على كل عناصر الحياه الحديثه
عبد العزيز التاسيس لكن اتوقع مهم نحكي عن
تاريخ الوجه او تاريخ المشروع متى بداوا
ايش كانت الفكره منه خليني اعطيك الفكره
الاساسيه اللي هي جميله جدا الفكره كانت
كان في فكره انه نكتب من الحرم الحرم يكون
متصل بدات الحرم يكون متصل في شارع
المنصور هذه اول حاجه اللي هي اول اشاره
تواجهك وانت جاي من جده صح لا قبلها حتى
قبلها
من ناحيه الحرملها اول شارع بعد الدائره
الاول او بعد الدائره الثانيه
بعدين الفكره تطورت انه نبغى يكون الحرم
متصل بطريق الامير محمد بن سلمان
كان في سته احياء عشوائيه في المنطقه
3626 عقار
هذا كان لابد من التعامل معها عشان الفكره
هذه تشير واقع
هذاك الوقت الشركه اخذت حوالي خمس سنوات
626 عقار
اتكلم عن شركه 2013 2012 قبل 2012 بدات
مساله
تاسيس الفكر تاسيس الشركه بدا التعامل مع
الناس واخذ وقف البدايه مساله الناس
تعويضات اخذت وقت في اشياء يعني شفناها في
المشروع
يعني كانت تجربه جميله جدا تعلمنا منها
كثير اخذت وقتها عشان نقدر ننساه اخذتها
خمس سنوات تقريبا حصل المنازل تفاهم مع
السكر ايجاد حلول يعني في بعض السكان عند
القروض على صندوق التنميه العقاري كيفك
الرهن احنا فكيناها كشركه وبعدين اعطينا
التعويض بعضهم ساعدناهم وفناهم سكن همم
لفترات مؤقته لغايه ما قدروا يروحوا
يسكنوا في عوائل ما عندهم ملكيه للبيت
بينما هي لها سنوات طويله ساكنه فيه فكان
في تجارب
الشركه والقائمين عليها فتح الوقت و
باشراف الدوله ثلاث حريص على التعامل مع
كل السكان
بافضل طريقه ممكنه واحنا فخورين على فكره
ما عندنا اي اشكالات مع السكان 3,626 عقار
اللي تمزعهم في ذلك الوقت بعد اخذنا سنتين
في هدم وتسويات الهدم كم كلفت عمليه النزع
11 مليار تكاليف النساء تصل الى 11 مليار
ريال سعودي 11 مليار هذا اللي اصحاب 300
تعويضات فقط وهذه من راس مال الشركه
مادام تكلمنا على راس المال منهم الشركه
في الشركه اليوم الشركه همم هي الصناديق
السياديه الحكوميه تملك نسب تصل الى 67%
والباقي من القطاع الخاص
التقاعد التامينات
ثم التقاعد التامينات الاوقاف همم
هل هم اخذوا الاوقاف اللي موجوده في
المكان عندهم اوقاف كانت ملكهههم معظم من
جهات الحكوميه دخلت بحكم عندها ممتلكات في
المنطقه عقارات
او لا هيئه الغيه هيئه الغيه المسؤوله عن
العقارات اللي معروفه اصحابها ولكن غير
موجود
[موسيقى]
فتم التعامل مع الموضوع بشكل جميل جدا
اليوم تصل ملكيه صناديق الحكوميه الى 67%
والقطاع الخاص اللي كان عندهم اراضي في
المنطقه دخلوا شركه نسبتهم حوالي 33%
فخلصنا مرحله النازع والتعويض دخلنا مرحله
الهدم هذه متى بدات
مرحله الهدم بعد 2012 بدا مرحله الهدم
ومرحله التخطيط
لما دخلنا في فرحه التخطيط
انت بتتكلم على موقع
حساس جدا
مليون و200 متر
المنطقه المنطقه هذه غير موجوده هتصبح
شريان رئيسي للحرم
كانت الفكره الرئيسيه في وقتها كيف تقدر
نصنع
منطقه تساهم في سهوله الوصول للحرب
ويكون فيه مشروع
يكتب خدمات اللي تحتاجها المدينه في مدينه
مكه
في موقع زي الموقع اللي احنا فيه
حاولنا
ندرسنا احتياجات المدينه وتوقعاتنا ليه
فترات طويله جدا
وحاولنا نغطي كافه الاحتياجات والتوقعات
سواء كان في مدينه مكه انت ما تفكر فقط في
سكان المدينه تفكر في الزوار انت عندك
اثنين مليون مسلم
حلمهم رحله حلمهم انهم اييي يزوروا مدينه
مكه ويزوروا الحرم
فاخذتها في الاعتبارات تحملنا مع افضل
مكاتب الاستشاريه من حول العالم على فكره
اخذنا كل الافكار ولكن كانوا مهندسين
سعوديين القائمين على المشروع من عندنا
اخذنا تخطيط للمشروع فترات طويله خلصنا في
البدايه المخطط العام بعدين ظهرت فكره
مترو مكه فطرينا نعيد المخطط طبعا بعد ما
خلصنا
بشكل احتوي على انفاق للمترو
تحت المشروع المشروع اليوم لما تروحوا
يمكن الناس ما تعرف تشوف فوق ما تشوف
اشياء كثير هو في خدمات مدينه تحت الارض
تخدم هالمشروع للميه السنه القادمه
في التخطيط مهم جدا خصوصا في منطقه مثل
مكه وكم تكلفه مرحله الازاله
وعلوم التحتيه اللي اليوم اكتمل تقريبا
80% اليوم لما نجمع كل التكاليف التعويضات
الازاله التخطيط البنيه التحتيه احنا
عملنا بنيه تحتيه في مكه غير مسبوقه اعطني
مثال ايش الملامح الموجوده فيها
المستقبليه حقت مكه معمول حسابه
منتهيه بالكامل على فكره وغيره
اول شيء في طريق الملك عبد العزيز هذا
الطريق
ياخذك من الكباري احنا بنين الكباري اللي
تحتك من طريق الامير محمد بن سلمان اليوم
انت رايح لمكه تروح على اليسار على
كان زمان اسمه شارع ام القرى هل اصبح
امتداد لطريق الامير محمد بن سلمان حتشوف
وجهك في كباري مبنيه حتتصل بطريقه الامير
محمد بن سلمان هذه حتى اختك الى
اقرب نقطه عند الحرب
في طريق رايح في عرض
يوديك للحرم بعرض 40 متر بعدين ترجع في
طريقه يخرجك من الحرام له طريق الامير
محمد بن سلمان
ايضا 40 متر
في اراضي هيتم تطويرها بجانب الطريق
وبعدين في النصف في مرموشه بطول 3 كيلو
ونص في اراضي تطويريه حوالين الممر هذا
عرضه 60 متر الممر
طوله 3.5 وهذا ما تخترقوا السيارات هذا لا
توجد هذه
السياره ممكن تدعسك واحد اهم
المخاطر اللي تعرضوا لها زوار مكه هي حركه
السيارات
على مفهوم الحركه الشامله بمعنى في فصل
تام ما بين حركه المشاه وحركه السيارات
ما في اي سياره وعشان تتحرك من اقصى
اليمين لاقص اليسار
في انفاق مشاه 11 نفق وجسر ينقلك من غير
ما تتعرض لاي سيارات فك تم التفادي احتكاك
المشاوي السيارات بالكامل ففي طريق
السيارات في طريق المشاه وفي كمان في
ترامب او في في انفاق المترو اوكي انفاق
المترو هذه
رف المشروع مترو مكه حيستفيد منها هو جزء
من المخطط حق متر مكه لو تاجل المشروع
احنا هنستخدمها ان شاء الله حيث انه اليوم
محطه القطار المحطه الحرمين اللي بين
المدينه جدا مكه 100 متر من مشروعنا تخرج
منه المحطه تدخل على مشروعنا في العاده في
العالم كله متعودين يخرج من محطه قطار
يركب المترو يوصلوا لاقرب نقطه
فمخططه بالشكل هذا لو ما اكتملت او تم
تاجيل متر مكه عندنا خطه بديله انه شغال
همم
فبه هي ازاي اللي في المطارات اليوم لما
تنزل في مطار الصلاه بعيده تفتح القطار
حنستخدم نفس وعندنا دراساتنا جاهسه
والمشغلين جاهزين ولكن منتظرين نصل للتصور
النهائي بالنسبه هذا كله بنيه تحتيه طيب
البنيه الفوقيه ويش بيكون فيه
البنيه الفوقيه الله يسلمك هيكون عندنا
24,000 غرفه فندقيه
24000 ثانيه همم شقه فندقيه شقوق الفندقيه
في مكه مهمه جدا بالذات لما تكون الزيارات
عائليه صح همم عندنا 13000
همم شقه سكنيه
عندنا ثلاثه مولات تجاريه
وعلى طول ممر المشاه هيكون في واجهه مسار
اللي هي كلها محلات همم مطاعم
[موسيقى]
مقاهي متاحف في منتصف المشروع في ساحه
مسجد كبيره جدا
141000 تتوسط المشروع هالساحه المسجد يشيل
14 الف داخل المسجد 40,000 مع الساحات
فهذه كلها امتداد للحرم
[موسيقى]
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر نبدع
في تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول
بكفاءه وذكاء سلوشن سبايسي
[موسيقى]
ومين مسؤول عن تطوير البنيه الفوقيه انتم
حتى تطورونها هذا سؤال مهم جدا هذا سؤال
مهم
احنا طورنا البنيه التحتيه وحنطور اجزاءنا
المشروع الرئيسيه مرتبطه ببنيه التحتيه
منها اللي اعلن اوقعناها الاسبوع الماضي
سبعه ابراج فندقيه ومولين تجاريه ولكن
احنا
قررنا انكم غلطه جبل عمر
جبل عمر تجربه مهمه لابد من الاستفاده من
نجاحاتها واذا كان عندها اخطاء لابد من
التعلم من اخطائها
ولكن للاستثمار في مكه كان في السابق
قائم على قبل ما تيجي الرؤيا كان قائم على
اجتهادات فرديه
اليوم التطوير العقاري احنا خرجنا من
مساله التطوير العقاري ودخلنا في صناعه
لمدير الموضوع بشكل تناسب مع الرؤيا
الرؤيه جاءت اعطتها خارطه الطريق
فيما يخص مكه على الاقل
انت انا مستهدف واضح 20 30 نبقى نصل ل 30
مليون عندنا المستهدفات واضحه تحسين
وتعميق التجربه الدينيه والروحانيه تحسين
تجربه الزائر تقديم خدمات ذات جوده عاليه
هاتي كلها عناصر مهمه جدا
احنا
ما نبغى نعيد اختراع العشره
[موسيقى]
نتعلم مثلا انا عندي اكبر مول في مكه
اللي هي عندها في الرياض الرياض بارك
عندهم خبره تراكميه ويعرفوا كيف يدير امور
وكيف ابنوه بافضل طريقه ممكنه ويشغلوه
بافضل طريقه ممكنه
المستشفى احنا اول شيء لما تتصنع وجهها
انت تفكر في احتياجات المدينه تفكر في
سلوكيات الزوار توقعاتهم فاحنا عندنا
عنصرين الرئيسيين احتياجات المدينه للميه
سنه القادمه ورغبات واحتياجات الزوار اللي
بيزوروا مدينه مكه
فبلينا المدينه على او مدينه روشه على هذا
الاساس اننا درسنا عشر احتياجات
عملنا منظومه استثماريه كامله
ودخلنا بالفكر الجديد ان نحن اليوم ليش
احنا نعيد اختراع العجل العجل او اخترعه
وانت انا مستثمرين متفوقين في انشطهم
عملنا ايكو سيستم كامل
عندي اليوم 205 قطعه ارض تطويريه ال 205
انا ما ببيعك ارض
في العاده في مكه او حتى بقيت مدن المملكه
تثبيع العرض وانت تطلع منها اختاري اللي
تبغاه بافضل استخدام تروح تطلع تراخيص روح
تدور على الكهرباء تدور على المويه تدور
على الخدمات انا اليوم
في وجهه مسار انا اعطيتك منظومه استثماريه
متكامل
اعمل ليمون وشغله بافضل طريقه ممكنه كل
شيء وصل مويه كهرباء تبريد مركزي خدمات
اداره حتى فكرنا ما نبغى السيارات اللي
تيجي وتدخل وتشيل الله المخلفات
بحيث انها تسبب ااا ازعاج زحمه اييي تلوث
وجبنا نظام عشان النفايات تكون بطريقه
مركزيه
بالتقنيه تسحبها كلها في مرمى جاهز فكلنا
كل شيء فانت اليوم تيجي
خبره تراكميه في نشاط معين انت ما تدخل في
اشكالات يعني دائما احد التحديات اللي
تواجهها المستثمرين في مكه تراخيص في
اجراءات كثير في جهاد
في الخدمات
الرسميه بمرسوم
كل شيء وسط تعال اعطيني خبرتك وانا مسؤول
عن الباقي كله وانا مسؤول عن تكامل
التجربه بس انا اشتري الارض ولا ادخل شريك
في الشركه انت انت اليوم تتعامل مع الشركه
ما تدخل شيء فيها الشركه ليها ملاك احنا
بنتكلم
هامات اشترت قطعه المول صح دخلت معنا
كل قطعه ارض
لها هي ما نسميها قطط نحن نسميها 205 فرصه
استثماريه لعندنا مخطط عامه
عندي
احنا درسنا ايش الاشياء اللي استراتيجيا
لابد انها تكون عندنا سيطره عليها بشكل ما
لانها تاثر في الوجه او من عناصر الرئيسيه
لذلك همم المول
المول انا لما تجيني انت كمستر انا ما
بحكي هنا المكان ده انا عندي موال تجاري
المول التجاري هذا الايه
»
هذا اهم مؤشر في الاستثمار لو
خلينا نقول 10 العرار تحتاج تستثمر مليار
ريال حيلك عائد 10 ايرار خلال فتره زمنيه
معينه
هل
الفرصه استثماريه انا بدخل معك شريط
انتوا تدخلوا مع شريك ايوه
تكلفه التطوير
بالصيغه نتفق عليها قد تكون بس يعني الحين
ما فهمتو شلون انا وش وش وش شكل علاقتي
فيكم هل انا مالك ارض ولا انا مالك اسهم
مالك عرض
ولك علاقه
بقدم لك الخدمات اللي موجوده في الوجهه
احنا حتكون شريك احيانا تاجر الارض
فاحنا عندنا كل الصيغ الممكنه اللي تجعل
الاستثمار مريحه الطرفين احد اهم العناصر
اللي احنا حريصين عليها في العلاقه
التعاقديه
وهذا اللي يفرق صناعه الوجه بين التطوير
العقاري في التطوير العقاري انت عندك
مونتاج لفئه معينه الاهداف معينه تنتهي
علاقتك لما سلمهم منتج تبيع المنتج باعلى
قيمه ممكنه
تنتهي علاقتك بتاع الموضوع انا عندي بنات
بورش جيتيني
بوش بعتلك اياه باعلى سعر ممكن انتهت
العلاقه احنا علاقتنا مستمره علاقتنا
التفاعليه لان احنا بنديل صحتنا وحده لذلك
نحن حريصين اي شخص يشتري ياجر يدخل معانا
شريك انه العلاقه تكون احنا الاثنين
كسبانين ممتاز خليني ارجع ارخصها واقول لو
افترض اني انا ببني برج في وجهه مسار
وببيع الخارطه نعم وش طبيعه العلاقه اذا
انتم في منطقه الابراج منطقه منطقه الشقق
الفندقيه اخذ برجعه على الخارطه انفذه
واطلع من المكان انا موجود انت موجود انا
موجود اللي بادير
لك الرسوم السنويه لمقابل الخدمات حق
المكان فهذا مثلا صيغه من الصيغ اللي
متاحه موجوده
حلو
يعني لو تكلمنا نحنا على الاساس في هذا
الوجه هي السكن يعني انت تتكلم على سواء
شقق او غرف فندقيه هذه اساس المنطقه
بدونها الوجه امام همم ما لها قيمه يعني
همم بس ما شفت ابدا اي حديث عن همم
تطويركم لهذا ال- ال- وحدات سكنيه فهو
الشيء اللي انتم بتشتغلوا عليه في البنيه
الفوقيه البنيه الفوقيه بالعكس احنا يمكن
خلينا ارجع للوراء شويه او صفقه نفسها
كانت همم التجاري مع الحبيب المستشفى
ليش طلب ماشي
احتياجات المدينه
اليوم المدينه اييه في مكه ما فيها مولات
بشكل الموجود في الرياض او جده كثير من
سكان مكه خلال عطله نهايه الاسبوع
ياخذ عياله ويقعد في المول ياكله ويشربوا
ويتفرج
ما في حاجه لما يكون في مراجعه دكتور
ينزلوا جتا
كذلك في دراسه عملتها غرفه مكه 2018
العالم الاسلامي سالت
ايش اهم هل ممكن تستفركا كلهم مرحبين
اسالهم ايش هالاشياء اللي ممكن تحديات
اللي يعني تخليكم تتردد انكم تاخذوا
القرار هذا
ولكن اهم كانت عنصرين كانوا نحن هنشتريه
في الحرم انا سعيد جدا
شهور فائقه
[موسيقى]
فلذلك نحن بدينا
بالاحتياجات الحاليه للمدينه اعتناها
اولويه فبدينا ورحنا لافضل مشغل من افضل
المشغلين المولات في السعوديه هامات
من افضل المستشفيات في الشرق الاوسط
مستشفى سليمان فقيه
كذلك من ناحيه استثماريه استراتيجيه احنا
اعطنا بعد تجربه في الاعوام الماضيه بنركز
ايضا
تكون عندنا عوائد ما هي مرتبطه بشكل مباشر
بالحج والعمره حيث تعطينا تنوع ما نواجه
لو لقدر الله حصل اي وباء في المستقبل
وزوار توقف الاي سبب انا عندي مصادر داخل
غير مرتبطه بشكل مباشر
بالحج والعمره وهذا تفكير استثماري ايضا
يتناسب مع احتياجات المدينه توقعات السكان
رغبات الزوار
فهذا هذه الاشياء اللي العمل في اطار
الرؤيا انت بتعمل بطريقه مختلفه
اتذكر قريته انه تكفه المشروع المقدره هي
100 مليار نعم انتم حتى الان صرفتوا حدود
35 مليار بنهايه العام هتكون اجمالي
للاستثمارات اللي نفذت تقدر 35 مليار 35
مليار السنه هذه همم بقيه ال 65 مليار هذه
منكم ولا من المستثمرين اللي يحوجون يبنون
هذه البنيه الفوقيه ولو شلون هيك تمويه
احنا كنا حريصين نجم فكره جديد
نخلط منظومه استثماريه شافته
لي
نوعيه المستثمرين عندنا في معاصرين مهمه
لازم يتوفر فيهم اهم عيار ان يكون عنده
خبره تراكميه في النشاط اللي جاي ينفذه زي
ما قلت لك انا ما بيكره انا حبيع فندق
فندق
الرحمن
في المطاعم سواء في الخدمات سوا يعني على
سبيل المثال احنا جبنا نتائج
السعوديه تاج مرتبط مع فئه معينه
بعدين حتى الفنادق على فكره انت اليوم في
صناعه الضيافه في العالم الفنادق اصبحت
مركزه في 3/4 سلاسل يعني ما هي ما هي ما
هي كثير فمهم يكون عندك تنوع في هل همم
الخدمه يعني كل الهيلتون عندهم جروب
الماريوت عندهم جروب همم جراند حياه عندهم
هذه الاسماء الرئيسيه تحت كل واحد فيهم في
لا يقل عن 50 براند كل براند عندها ولا
عندها عملاء عندها شبكه حجوزات وهذه
المهمه اليوم بيكون عندك اتصال بشبكات
الحجوزات والناس تكون همم تعرف هالخدمه
الاسيويين عندهم رغبات الهنود عندهم رغبات
الاندلس عندهم الغابات الماليزيين فاحنا
بنحاول يكون عندنا خدمه متنوعه
عشان كده بقول لك منظومه استثماريه
متكامله احنا دارسين كل التفاصيل وكيف
نقدر نقدم الخدمات اللي يبحثوا عنها
الزوار السكان
اييي يمكن من الاشياء اللي لافته تضل ايام
سنه واقف في الشباك وطالع المنطقه
المركزيه
ما لقيته ولا نقطه خضره
ولا نقطه خضره في كامل المنطقه المركزيه
كل مشاريع لتطويل الي قاعده تصير حوالين
الحرم ما في ولا نبته ولا شجره فالصراحه
منظر يعني ما هو ما هو مريح ابدا ولا هو
صحي وله مستدام للمكان فكم مساهمتكم في
هدف العشره مليار شجره
ده الرقم لسه ما هو عندنا ولكن عندنا
توجيهات واضحه واحنا بعمل حساباتها ولكن
اليوم بنعيد الحسابات بالشكل اللي تناسب
مع المبادره مهم جدا يعني اليوم احنا نقلت
لك لما نخلق حياه جزء مهم من الحياه
المناظر في الطبيعه اليوم ما بدي سبق
الاحداث بس احنا
بنتكلم مع جهاد حكوميه
في مشاريع بجوار المنطقه حكتنا جميله جدا
في الاعتبار وهذه الان عشان كده ما اعطيتك
رقم احنا بنشتغل عليها لانه احنا في مكه
الله يسلمك عندنا اعتبارات مهمه لابد
اخذها في الاعتبار
اداره الحدود
الممر هذا احنا عملنا حساباتنا
في الميه السنه القادمه توقعنا انه كل
المناطق المحيطه يتم تطويرها ونصبح احلى
الطريق للحرم
فات معناته احنا اليوم بنتكلم مع الجهات
المسؤوله جهات الحكوميه اللي ماسك الملفات
على في 2035 عندنا توقعات في مناطق يكون
فيها اختناقات كيف نقدر اليوم
نتكلم على 35 في مناطق حسب الدراسات
المتوفره عندنا قد يكون فيها اختناقات
نتيجه المناطق المجاوره كلها طورت
وهيستخدمه مشروعنا كم لما اعمل تشير ما
اقدر اسرع شجره عشان اخليها خضراء وتعيق
حركه الاسود احنا لابد من اخذ كل
الاعتبارات ولكن نحن وصلنا مرحله متقدمه
والان
بنجد الحلول المناسبه ولكن مهم جدا
المبادره مهمه
احنا حريصين على
اخراج المنطقه بشكل جديد يمكن من ملاحظات
اللي دائما تتكرر على على فنادق وخدمات
المنطقه المركزيه انها
[موسيقى]
موازي او اعلى من اسعار العالم لكنها اقل
بكثير في وفره الخيارات يعني تسكن مثلا في
في جبل عمر فندق خمس نجوم ولا في فيرمونت
ولا في اداره التوحيد
دفع 2000 ريال في الليل على الغرفه في
فندق ما في جنب ما في نادي صحي هذه بعض
الناس يمكن مثلا ينظرونها مهمه اولويه
الواحد رايح مكه بس هذا مو صحيح في ناس
همم
مكه منطقه اللي همم الراحه النفسيه
المنطقه اللي همم الارتباط بالله سبحانه
وتعالى
بعده اشكال مختلفه ليست دائما كلها
بالضروره في مبنى الحرم قد اكون انا في
الغرفه ومحتاج اني همم يعني امارس نمط
حياتي اللي انا بعت هذا واروح العرب ما في
تعارض بينهم
في كده عرف صاير عند فنادق مكه انه دائما
هي اقل قدر ممكن من الخيرات يعني ما في
ولا فندق مثال بسيط مثلا
انا انا اتفق معك ان الخدمات اللي مقدمه
في مكه وهذا مرعيه هذا راي الدراسات اللي
قامت بها برنامج ضيوف الرحمن وزاره
السياحه اليوم وزاره السياحه متبنيه
نظام جديد لتصنيف الفنادق النظام العالمي
في تفاصيل
مكه
بالاستطلاعات اللي عملوها ان الخدمات
جودتها اقل من اللي المفروض تقدم فيه في
مدينه مثل مكه يفترض انها زي كل المدن
العالميه بالافضل لانه اللي جايه جايه
ان احنا اليوم هنعرف الوجه بمعايير عالميه
احنا اليوم ماشيين في افضل
طبعا في هذا الاشتراك انا اعطيك اعطيك
معلومه رسميه موجوده
81% من الفنادق اللي موجود من الفنادق
اللي موجوده في مكه
اقل من فئه ثلاث نجوم اقل من الفئه ثلاث
نجوم
فاحنا لما نتكلم احيانا الناس تقول ان
الفنادق ما هي شغاله مش هذه كلها لازم كان
العمل في السابق بطريقه فرديه ما كان فيه
معلومات ما في بيانات ما في جهات رسميه
عندها خطه واضحه
ودراسات واضحه وبيانات ومعلومات تتخذ على
اساسها القرار اليوم عندنا يعني برامج
الرؤيه برنامج ضيوف الرحمن متطرق لكل
تفاصيل اللي تكلمنا عنها الخدمات سواء على
فكره بس
خدمات الخمسه نشوف الاكل
الخدمات المسانده
التنقل احنا احنا ضمن الاشياء اللي كنا
حريصين عليها
عندنا حوالين الوجه خدمه تنقل
باصات تردديه 24 ساعه احنا مخصصين لها
يعني عاده الباصات توقف على اليمين احنا
مخليها هتوقف على اليسار عشان تدخل على
الوجه مباشره
في تفاصيل
عشان كده بقول لك الدراسات اخذت وقت
لانه خطط للوجه واخذنا في اعتباراتنا انها
تكون تتوافق مع المعايير العالميه انها
تكون للمئه السنه القادمه بقول ال 100 سنه
الخاتمه احنا اليوم نعرف التقنيات
الموجوده انت تعمل تخلي الوجهها فيها
مرونه بحيث انها زي الايفون حقك كل فتره
يجيك برنامج تعمل له ابريت
احنا صنعنا الوجه بهذه الطريقه
تستوعب بمشيئه الله 158,000
ساكن وزائر في نفس الوقت نعم كم منهم ساكن
دائم وكم من هم بندقي 30% هيكونوا سكان
33% بالضبط سكان دائمين 6% هيكونوا موظفين
يعملوا في الوجهه الوجه حسب الدراسات
المتوفره عندنا حاتم في بشكل مباشر وغير
مباشر في صناعه وظائف اكثر من 100,000
مشاهده
[موسيقى]
وواحده من وسائل التمويل المعتاده في
مشاريع العقاري هي البيع الخارقه واليوم
الوجهها بالنسبه الكثيرين تعتبر همم اللي
هي مكه المكرمه همم محطه سنويا ثابته ان
في الصيف اما في رمضان همم بس الي الان ما
سوقته موضوع ال- ال- الوحدات التملك هذه
اللي انا متاكد كثير هيحرس انه اليوم
يشتريها حتى على الخارطه للموقع ممتاز على
قطار الحرمين على همم وصول سهل لمكه مقابل
دامك مول جنبك مستشفى تروح على رجلك رمضان
تقعد هناك وانت مرتاح اكثر اكثر من 30 يوم
همم ليش ما بدات في هذا المجال بدينا طال
عمرك
10 ابراج سكنيه
هيبدا الاول برجين هيبداوا فيهم الان في
عماله تجهيزات اتوقع 23 حيبدا البيعه على
الخارطه بمشيئه الله انت تعرف في البدايه
احنا الان اول مشاريع بنقوم فيها ففي
البدايه شغالين في التراخيص والاشياء هذه
ونص تطلع خلاص
لمده زمنيه زي المشاريع الثانيه
المده الزمنيه قد يجي لما يسمح لي غير
السعوديين من النوم
من مده طويله اكيد عندك علم
حسب المعلومات المتوفره انها الملف في
مراحل متقدمه جدا ان شاء الله نسمع انه
قريب المفروض يصبح لغير المسلمين الغير
السعوديين والخليجيين انه يمتلكون حق
الدفاع حقا يعني في الاغلب هيكون حق
انتفاع لمده زمنيه طويله وموجود مطبق فيه
في العالم ما هو حاجه جديده اول مره يعني
ما في في في المنطقه المركزيه السابقه
بالطريقه هذه لا ما في اكثر من سنتين ما
فيش حاجه همم ما كان موجود فيه حق الدفاع
هو ايجار كان همم قريت الخبر لكم تنوين
الطرح الكتاب العام همم وشايفكم ما شاء
الله شادين حيلكم اعلاميا هذه دائما مؤشر
اذا شفت الشركه ساكته وفجاه بدها تسولف
ابعثوا انه عندهم الطرح مدير
جديد
لكن خليني اقول لك فلسفه الشركه فلسفه
الشركه خصوصا في التطوير العقارب في
السعوديه في مراحل معينه
المطورين يطلعوا يوعدوا اكثر مما ينفذوا
فلسفه الشركه انه نحن نطلع نقول اللي
سويناه
فلذلك يمكن في الفترات الماضيه ما سمعت
عنها لانه ما كان في حاجه لسه نقدر نقول
عنه الان كل شيء نوصل فيه
انه كل الاشياء الان بدات تظهر نتيجه عمل
السنوات السابقه اللي كان في سلط
الفكره
موجوده احنا شغالين فيها التوقيت هيكون
افضل توقيت مناسب بعد الحصول على كافه
الاجراءات احنا خلصنا اجزاء كبيره من
حوكمه والاشياء المهمه جدا من الداخل
خلصناها الان شغالين مع المستشارين مالين
نختار افضل توقيت لما الجهاز الرسميه
توافق عليها متى اول استخدام للشخص العادي
لاي مرفق من المرافق الوجهه متى اول مره
يقدر يزورها اول مره هتزور الوجه بمشيئه
الله في العام 2023 هتجيء نمشي سوا في ممر
المشاه الثلاثه ونص كيلو كامل راح يكون
جاهز والطريق السوق سيارتك
نمشي انت هتختار 23
من المطار في جده
ونوقف السياره ونطلع
في الوجه الطالب
بالطريقه الملك عبد العزيز طريق الملك عبد
العزيز هذا للسيارات هذا عام كم 23 23
بعدها 24 اتوقع انه في 24 حتكون اول برجين
سكنيه انتهت
25 هيكون 7 ابراج الفندقيه اللي تكلمنا
عليها تكون انتهت المول قد يكون انتهى
بنهايه 25
27 يمكن النهايه 26 المستشفى
اللي شويه هم الناس الموضوع همم اقصد من
زاويه الرؤيا موضوع المحتوى المحلي الوجه
هذه ينفق فيها 100 مليار اليوم في سياسات
همم حكوميه صارمه في تشجيع المحتوى المحلي
هل عندكم اي شيء في هذا المجال هل عندكم
نسبه المحتوى المحلي
يعني لما مثلا الصندوق صنافات العامه عنده
سياسه انه 60% من الانفاق او اكثر يكون في
المحلي 60% يكون محلي نعم نحن متوافقين
معاه كل السياسات للدوله تقرها والصندوق
الحقيقه شريك مهم ان احنا بنستفيد ايضا زي
ما قلت لك احنا بنستفيد من المستثمرين
الخبرات التراكميه احنا عندنا مساهم من
اكبر المشاهدين في الشركه
من اكبر المستثمرين في العالم
انت شريكه الصندوق تروح تاخذ
بس اللي توصل له اللي فات كم كم صرفته 21
مليار غير التعويضات كملها تعويضات كلها
محتوى محلي التعويضات كلها محتوى محلي
المواد اللي جوه احنا احنا عاينا مقاولين
احنا ما نفذ نفسنا بس انت تشرط على
المقاول طبعا شركه البحر الاحمر
في الامارات نقلت لرابغ بس عشان تاخذ عقود
ضخم تقدروا تاثرون على احنا في الفتره
الماضيه تجاوزنا 40% او في حدود ال40%
محتوى محلي كل الشركات المحليه
خساره الحديد
والخرسانه اللي استخدمناها والحديد كميات
مهوله على فكره لانه احنا بنتكلم انا عندي
انفاق خدمات لما اقول لك انفخ خدمات
ممكن
ممكن المشاهدين يقدروا سوا
الخدماتنا مفاجاه الخدمات هذه تحت الطريق
الكهرباء المويه همم الصرف الصحي الله
يكرمك كلها اشياء تحت الطريق بمعنى في
المستقبل طريقه لما رجع عبد العزيز افتتح
ما يتم حفره عشان نصلح ماسوره ولا عشان
نركب همم كيبل
كلها انفاق 14 كيلو خدمات هذه كلها تحت
الطريق لما احتاج حاجه ادخل انا في النفق
يصلحها انت ما تدري عنها فوق
والان ابو عبد العزيز اباك تخلع شويه قبعه
الرئيس التنفيذي وتلبس قبعه المختص في
منطقه
يعني تجربه الزائر او الفرس اللي في
المنطقه المركزيه بقتبس لك واحد اسمه عمر
العبدلي عمر عبيدلي مدير ابحاث ومركز
دراسات البحثفي يقول
على عكس قطاع الطاقه الذي يتعين على
المملكه دائما ان تقلق بشان المنافس
المستقبلين ففي مجال الحج والعمره
السعوديه تضمن عدم وجود اي منافسه الى
الابد التهديد الوحيد الذي واجهه طموحات
السعوديه في الاستفاده من الحج هو تقليص
التدين في العالم لكن طالما استمر
المسلمون في الرغبه في زياده هذا الموقع
فسوف يمثلون فرصه الاقتصاديه هائله
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه ايش اهم الفرص
اللي موجوده اليوم في في همم خدمه الضيوف
الرحمن
صور في قطاعكم الضيافه او التطوير العقاري
او تطوير وجهات
الى قطاعات الاشمل من ذلك انا اعتقد انه
هذه اهم صناعه
في السابق
ما اهتمينا فيها بشكل
كصناع
احنا كنا نستقبل الزوار والراغبين ممكن
تمليهم افضل خدمات ممكنه من غير ما نحطها
في نموذج اعمال
اليوم بعد وجود الرؤيا
بعد
ظهور برنامج ضيوف الرحمن
بندرس
كيف نقدم افضل خدمه قبل
واثناء وبعد الزياره
الزياره ما تبدا لما توصلني الزياره تبدا
من تخطيطك للوصول احنا لم يسبق انه سوقنا
ليه العمره للحج في الماضي
ايش الاشكلات اللي كانت موجوده
انه العمل بطريقه فرديه زي ما قلت لك انا
عندي خبره معينه عندي تصور انه ابقى اختم
المعتمرين هي كلها كانت 3 شهور في السنه
وبقيه السنه عندك طاقه استيعابيه مهمله
اليوم بنتكلم
بكلامك اليوم كيف اقدر افعل الطاقه هذه
كيف اخلي العمره هذه طول السنه اليوم احنا
وصلنا
مكان خروج المعتمر من بلده عشان نختمه
اعطيك مثال بسيط
ضمن انجازات الرحمن
التاشيره كانت تاخذ في احسن اوقات 14 يوم
خمسه دقائق
اليوم
وصل
مده انتظار الزائر في كافه المنافذ 15
دقيقه
اليوم احنا بنتكلم على معلومات وبيانات
احنا ما كنا نعرف هذا الشركياته ايش
توقعاته ايش اسوي لما يجي عندك
الحبيب اللي بنى
عماره وسكن فيها يعرف
احنا عندنا جهات رسميه متابعه كل شيء وحطه
مؤشرات اداء بمعنى اليوم احنا في 25 في
مؤشر اداء قياس رضا الزوار المؤشر يفترض
انه يكون لا يقل عن 85% في 25
حيث يصل لاكثر من 90% في 20 30 وهذا يعتمد
على الخدمات المقدمه له اليوم احنا بندرس
كل مليون ما تبدا تفكر يعني اكثر ان شاء
الله حنوصل انه خليك تفكر
انك تشبع تعمل عمره وانا ما اتفق معه
كلامه ممتاز ما اتفق مع انه الدين او
الاهتمام بالروحانيات خف انا ما اتفق انا
اعتقد بالعكس
الجانب هذا مهم جدا خصوصا اليوم في ظل
الرؤيا احنا اليوم ما المفروض انه وجهه
مسار تشتغل لوحدها
احنا ربنا يعني زي ما قلت مكه موجوده
الناس كلها بتجيها اليوم لازم وجهت مسار
تكون هي البوابه لي بقيه الوجهات بمعنى
اليوم انا كوجهه مسار انا ابا اعطيك ااا
بكش تجيني تقضي عندي ثلاثه اربعه ايام
تستمتع بالحرام تقدي مناسك عم تعمل كل
الروحانيات اللي تحتاجها بافضل طريقه
ممكنه بعدين تروح العلا وبعدين تروح على
البحر الاحمر
انت الناس اليوم في العالم
تبحث عن المعنى بذلك هي تروح الى الاشياء
الدينيه لما تكون مريحه لها العالم اللي
احنا فيه اليوم في زحمه وفي شغل وفي
ضغوطات وفي توتر تبحث عن
اتصالك بالخالق كيف تقدر تسترجع نفسك
هي المستقبل الاستثمار في مكه انا ابغى
وجهه مسار تكون هي المدخل
للوجهات الجميله
الممتعه اللي بنعملها اليوم
ما في جدال لانه لم لم يعني لم يختم الحرم
المكي في تاريخه باللي حدث في الدوله
السعوديه اداء الله والانفاق الهائل
والجوده العاليه اللي قاعده تصير في مبنى
الحرم وتصير في خدمه ويفرحنا داخل الحرم
يمكن التحدي هو
قبل ما تدخل الحرب دائما المعاناه يعني لو
تتكلم على موضوع الروحانيه روحانيه كلها
ترا تتلف وتنتهي في المشقه اللي قاعده
تصاحبك من يوم ما طلعت المطار لان توصل
لبوابه الحرب من ناحيه الطرق من ناحيه
الزحام من ناحيه
وضوح المسارات المروريه يعني انت تستاجر
في الغرفه وما تدري المرور بخليك تدخل
منطقه تحت في القلب
ال ال الفندق حقك ما تلقى همم
التجربه الوصول الى طب انا انا صليت العصر
في الحرب رجعت الغرفه قراءه القران طيب
وصليت المغرب في الحرم رجعت الغرفه
صليت العشاء رجعت الغرفه طيب بعدها ابغى
متحف مرتب يحكي لي تاريخ
الحضاره الاسلاميه ابغى مكان مرتب يحكي لي
عن همم ابرز علماء المسلمين اللي نشاوا
وعاشوا في مكه المكرمه هذه كلها اليوم
مفقوده ويمكن يعني مسار همم يعني شركه او
او مشروع مساري يعني محفزه ويدعو التفاؤل
بس شويه المخيبه وبس ما رايك عن هذا الامر
هو انه في جهاز كنا نعول عليك كثير صار له
اربع سنوات متاسس كنت اعود عليه كثير همم
اللي هو الهيئه الملكيه لمكه المكرمه
مقدسها لكن الصراحه ادائهم من وجهه نظر
كثيرين مخيب جدا في الاربع سنوات الماضيه
يمكن الان في تغييرات الوزير الجديد
الرئيس التنفيذ الجديد مهند صالح الرشيد
بس الفتره اللي سبقت هذه الفتره فتره
مخيبه لا طلعنا بكود عمران يعني لو تروح
متمكن تلاقي اشكال المباني ما هو متناسقه
ما عندي هويه واحده بصريه للمدينه ما عندي
كل عنوان المدينه ما في مخطط عام او
استراتيجيه موحد لهذه المدينه همم ما في
تجربه زائر همم تراعي مختلف فئات وشرائح
المجتمع همم منطقه مكه المكرمه همم
فكل هذه الاشياء كنت انا شخصيا وعول على
الهيئه الملكيه هي المسؤوله عنها اللي
يتضح لي الامور ما كانت ماشيه بشكل جيد
ااا هيا اسست اعتقد في منتصف 2018
كيف تقيم تجربه الهيئه في الفتره الماضيه
يعني اعتقد الهيئه عندها جهات تقيمها
ومسؤوله عنها انا اعتقد ان التاسيس دائما
يواجه صعوبات وتحديات انا احب دائما ما
بتكلم على الماضي انا احب المستقبل انا
انا متفائل جدا بوجود المهندس صالح الرشيد
القائمين على هيئه اليوم يعني بنتكلم على
المستقبل على اشياء جميله جدا اجابه كلامك
كله اللي قلته صحيح وشهد ما صار انشئت
عشان كل الاشياء دي تتفتح اليوم انت هتوصل
مكه خليني انت السنه القادمه ان شاء الله
هتجيء يا ابو السياره يا بالقطار اول شيء
حيستقبلك هو وجهك نصر
هتدخل هتمشي تبقى باصه لترددي ما حد
السيارات ما حد شيء احنا اليوم حنستقبلك
وهنقول لك متى افضل وقت تروح الحرم فيه
ترى فيه مطعم فلانه تحتاج انك تجربه
رئيس التنفي
انا بحاول اشرح لك
وجهك بسعر هي
النموذجيه للي انت بتقوله بالضبط اللي انت
بتقوله بالضبط احنا شغالين فيه بس
ما تم اعلان لانه ما انت
هذه كل الاشياء ترى اليوم الدوله برنامج
ضيوف الرحمن
بيتكلم عن
الطاقه الاستيعابيه للطيران
اليوم بيتكلم عن كيف انت اليوم بعض المدن
المهمه ما عندها خط مباشر مع جده مثلا
في كل الاشياء تيجي اليوم رؤيا كل
التفاصيل هذه ترى في تفاصيل اكثر منها كل
اللي انت بتقوله ضمن الاهداف اليوم نحنا
كيف تخلق التشويق
للعمره
وكيف نزيل الصوره الذهنيه انها العمره
ويمكن لغايه امس
العمره اللي يقوم فيها اما يقوموا فيها
مره واحده في عمرهم في رمضان
او لما يحجوا بسبب الصوره الذهنيه
المرتبطه بالعمره بالمشقه من يوم ما تبدا
تطلع تاشيره في السابق
في اليوم الدوله في برامج الرؤيا حاطه كل
التحديات اللي تواجه
كل الراغبين في الزياره ترى تحديات اكثر
من اللي تكلمنا فيها كثير
او اكثر من 30 نقطه احتكاك
بالزائر او ضيف الرحمن تمثل بالنسبه لتحدي
من لحظه التاشيره الى
مغادرته
سته انجازات تمت يعني منها سمع قلت لك انه
15 دقيقه في كافه منافذ المملكه
دخوله التاشيره خمسه دقائق الاهتمام في
المواقع التاريخيه
بحريه
وتاشيره العمره
في قرار السنه هذه همم
السماح اطلاق ملصق
اللي اظن انها هي صارت نفس الوحيده اللي
همم خدمات العمره صح صحيح اليوم
احنا ضمن الاشياء اللي بتدرسها برنامج
ضيوف الرحمن كيف تحقيق المنفعه الاقتصاديه
القصوى
للزائر بمعنى اليوم
الزاهر ما نبغى يدفع اموال لتعدد الوسطاء
كيف يقدر يدفع 10000 ريال كيف يقدر يحقق
اكثر منفعه من العشره الاف دوله هذا
البرنامج
كيف تاخذ افضل قيمه مقابل خمسه ريال الاف
ريال وكيف نقدر نتفادا تعدد الوسطه اللي
هو المعتمر في كثير من الدول تروح فلوسه
في الوسطها وهو ما ياخذ القيمه مقابل
اليوم اليوم احنا داخلين في تفاصيل حقيقي
يعني وبكل شفافيه يعني تدخل على موقع
برنامج ضيوف الرحمن تقرا كلها معلومات
سريه هذه معلومات يعني حتى اللي خارج
المملكه يقدر يدخل يقرا المعلومه هذه قمه
الشفافيه هذا دليل انت اليوم لما تحط
اهداف واضحه
انا لما اقول لك اني ابغى نسبه رضا تكتب
فوق ال 85% هذا يكون عندي 40 موقع تاريخي
اسلامي يعني مكه والمدينه هي كنش للتاريخ
الاسلامي
ما عندنا اي حاجه في السابق انت تعرف غار
حراء عشان توصل له ولا غار ثور قديش ما في
بنيه تحتيه اليوم كلها دي على فكره انتهت
انا ما كنت اقول ولكن ابشرك اني خلال
الاسابيع القادمه بمشيئه الله حاوقع متحف
فنون اسلاميه
في عالم متغير في منافسه انت تبقي تسقطب
نوعيات معينه الفئات ما عمرنا ركزنا على
فئات المعتمرين طول عمرنا
يجونا فئه معينه مثلا جنسيات معينه 6 7
جنسيات هي الزوار معظم سنه ما عملنا اي
تسويق ما تعاملنا مع الموضوع كان نموذج
عمل اليوم احنا بندرس الفئه اللي ما عمرها
جائت اصلا
بنحاول نقدم لها خدمات تليق فيها
يمكن من الاشياء اللي كانت تثير تساؤل
البعض هي موضوع مدد هذه المشاريع يعني
مثلا لما نشوف مشروع توسعه الحرم 13 سنه
قطار الحرمين عشر سنوات مطار جده ثمان
سنوات انتم الان صار لكم فوق 13 سنه ليش
طبيعه هذه المشاريع تاخذ هذه المده مع انه
في بداياتها كانت توقع اقل من كده بكثير
وايش المفاجاه اللي قاعده تتكرر في كل
المشاريع
كل مشروع على فكره ما تتشابه كلها في
اسباب عدم انجازه في فترات قصيره
في السابق تكلم على مشروعي مثلا عشان انا
اعرف
معالجه عشوائيات ما كانت في يعني
النماذج غير واضحه دائما في حرز من الدوله
على التعامل بشكل جيد مع هدول الناس ااا
التخطيط انت اليوم لمشروع زي مشروعي انا
ما اسوي ما صار في المنطقه هذه كل يوم انت
تعمل مره واحده
100 سنه وبعدين تعملوا مرن بشكل انه يستمر
في التطور يعني اليوم انت لما تروح بعد
المدن سنيورك المبنى له 100 سنه
ولكن اهميه المكان تخليه
لابد من انه يكون مرن وتطور احنا اهم من
اي مكان في العالم
مكه ليها اكثر من 3000 سنه حتى تستمر ان
شاء الله
على فكره اللي يجي مكه ما هو نفس المستثمر
اي مكان
مختلف جدا حتى تواجدهم هذا موسى
التحديات مختلفه
لمده اطول مرحله ما بعد النزع يعني يمكن
لا تتبعاتها وتحديات زي ما قلت لك احنا
خلصنا الماستر المخطط العام الجديد
فقررت الدوله في مصلحه المدينه انت في
النهايه مشروع
مصلحه المدينه تقدم دائما
فهذا السبب بعدين جاء كوففت اكثر كمان
سنتين يمكن لانه كفت ما هو الفتره اللي
حصل فيها همم
اكثر حتى الى اليوم بيعاني قطاع التطوير
من
مواد البناء
مو بس ارتفاع اسعارها عدم وجود احيانا
فالباضي تعلمنا منه
اليوم انا لما اقول لك ليش بقول لك انا
اليوم منظومه استثماريه عشان اللي انت
بتقوله ده ما عاد يتكرر لما تجيني انت يا
مطور الي عندك خبره تراكميه في مجال معين
تعال وريني خبرتك وما لك دعوه بالباقي كله
انا اتكفلت فيه وهذا كلام منطبق على اشياء
كثير في الدوله لو الدوله الحاليه مسكت
مطار
الملكه سنوات احنا تعلمنا من التجارب
والباطيه التجارب الماضيه فيها دروس كثير
ما كنا نتعلم الان تعلمنا الحمد لله يمكن
اكثر نستفيدين من وجهه مسار همم هي موضوع
الزوار وضيوف الرحمن وبعض سكان المدينه
لكن همم وهذا سؤال اخير ابو عبد العزيز
لاحظنا انه اليوم ال- ال- الشركات الكبرى
في السعوديه قاعده يمتد اثرها للمجتمع
المحلي بشكل اكبر من مجرد همم وظيفه
مباشره ولا خدمه تقدم بمقابل معدي في دور
تنموي غير اللي سوتوا ارامكو في الشرقيه
همم اثروا اجيال واجيال استفادت من وجود
ارامكو في الشرقيه البحر الاحمر اليوم
اللي قاعد يسوي في منطقه ام لجوء الوجه
اثرها نيوم في همم تبوك شمال المملكه اثر
هائل همم
يعني مكه اعتقد وسكان مكه وشباب مكه همم
سيستفيدون كثيرا من برامج تنمويه همم
ابتعاث او او تدريب او تاهيل او برامج
زماله اشياء من هذا النوع همم تحتاج الى
عملاق همم اقتصادي يستطيع ان يدخلها ضمن
برامج هذا المشاريعه همم
وهذه اثرها يمتد ابعد بكثير من مجرد
16,000
لفتره زمنيه معينه نتكلم لنهايه المشروع
اكثر فهوش الاثر على المجتمع المحلي على
سكان مكه على اهل مكه اللي ممكن يستفيدون
من هذا الوجه
ابدا لك من ليش احنا
ندعي ان احنا صناعه وجهك
ما احنا ما بنقول احنا مطول احنا صانع
وجهها صانع وجهه اليوم انا يا
استاذ عمر هاجيبك انت مستثمر عند خبره
تراكميه هتصنع نشاط مايا
انا دوري اليوم اني كيف هل مستثمرين كلهم
كل واحد عنده خبره تراكميه في النشاط معين
كيف اخلي التناسق والتناغم ما بين كافه
الانشطه هذه بحيث انها تخرج تجربه حتى دور
اليوم كاس صانع وجهك من ضمنها العنصر
البشري انت اليوم تبى تقدم خدمات بجوده
عاليه تبقى تقدم خدمات لفئات
تطلعاتها وتوقعاتها عاليه العنصر البشري
كبير انا اليوم
بالطبيعي اني هتبنى كيف اخرج كل اللي
يشتغلوا في الوجه هذه كيف يكونوا في مستوى
يليق بالتوقعات برامج تدريب تاهيل متخصصه
كيف اليوم اشجعوا هذا الاعمال من النقاط
اللي فيها ضعف في مكه
ما في منتج محلي
التنوع واعطاء الفرص لرواد الاعمال هذا
صانع الوجه اللي يقدر يعمله باشكال متعدده
هلا انا في النهايه شركه هدفها ربح صح
ولكن زي ما قلت لك انا زي ما اقدر اربح مع
الحبيب وفقيه ما اقدر اربح مع ياسر ومحمد
مو لازم تكون احنا حنشجع الافكار حنجرب
23 اكثر 23 انت اليوم لازم تبدا تشتغل على
التخطيط ولكن شغالين برنامج على فكره
تاهيل كل العاملين في المنظومه هذه انا
باخلق منظومه استثماريه سوري العنصر
البشري هو اللي يعمل الفرق الرؤيه كلها
قامت على مجتمع حيوي
الرحمن قبل شهرين وعلى طول مجموعهم
مبادراتهم بصراحه كانت مبهره جدا زرت نفسي
بعض المواقع مثلا تطوير الموقع غزوه احد
همم
في المدينه المنوره
همم ففي شغل رهيب من البرنامج همم بس اللي
انا اقصده همم الشركه نفسها كشركه عاده
يكون في مثلا اكاديميه لتاهيل تدريب شباب
مكه فيصير في اولويه همم خاصه لابناء مكه
انهم يتدربون ويتوظفون في بالضبط
[موسيقى]
البشري ونطوره بما يلي
في منطقه مكه ومدينه مكه الماليق بالمكان
اللي احنا موجودين فيه بما يليق بالرؤيه
ومستقبل السعوديه
لمئه سنه قدام بمئه مليون
تصنع تجربه
توازي مقدار فخرنا وشرفنا في خدمه الضيوف
الرحمن باذن الله تعالى ان شاء الله السنه
القادمه
الله يعطيك العافيه شكرا لكم
انتاج الحلقه ياسر الغانم وياسر كده في
الكاميرا وفي تسجيل الصوت عبد العزيز
المزيد وفي التحرير وفي الهندسه الصوتيه
محمد الحسن وفي الاشراف على الانتاج
[موسيقى]
احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزي